what do you make of
if we could take a a another of a
multitude of tangents
what do you make of fermat's last
theorem because the statement there's a
few theorems there's a few
problems that are deemed by the world
throughout its history to be
exceptionally difficult and
that one in particular is uh really
simple to formulate
and uh really hard to come up with a
proof for
and it was like taunted as simple
uh by from by himself is there something
interesting to be said about
that x to the n plus y to the n equals z
to the n for n
of three or greater is there a solution
to this
and then how do you go about proving
that like how would you
uh try to prove that and what do you
learn from
the proof that eventually emerged by
andrew wiles yeah so right to sort of
give
let me just say the background because i
don't know if everybody listening knows
the story so you know fermat
uh was an early number theorist at least
sort of an early mathematician those
special adjacent didn't really exist
back then um
he comes up in the book actually in the
context of um a different theorem of his
that has to do with
testing whether a number is prime or not
so i write about
he was one of the ones who was salty and
like he would exchange these letters
where
he and his correspondence would like try
to top each other and
vex each other with questions and stuff
like this but this particular thing
um it's called fermazl's theorem because
it's a note he wrote uh
in in his uh in his copy of the
description arithmetic eye like he wrote
here's an equation it has no solutions i
can prove it but
the proof's like a little too long to
fit in this in the margin of this
book he was just like writing a note to
himself now let me just say historically
we know that vermont did not have a
proof of this theorem for a long time
people like
you know people were like this
mysterious proof that was lost a very
romantic story right
but ferma later
he did prove special cases of this
theorem and
wrote about it talked to people about
the problem and it's very clear
from the way that he wrote where he can
solve certain examples of this type of
equation
that he did not know how to do the whole
thing
he may have had a deep
simple intuition about this how to solve
the whole thing that he had at that
moment
without ever being able to come up with
a complete proof and that intuition may
be lost the time
maybe but i think we i'm so but you're
right that is unknowable but i think
what we
can know is that later he certainly did
not think that he had a proof that he
was concealing from people he
yes uh he thought he didn't know how to
prove it and i also think he didn't know
how to prove it
now i understand the appeal of saying
like
wouldn't it be cool if this very simple
equation there was like a very simple
clever wonderful proof that you could do
in a page or two and
that would be great but you know what
there's lots of equations like that that
are solved by very clever methods like
that including
the special cases that female wrote
about the method of dissent which is
like very wonderful and important
but in the end those are
nice things that like you know you teach
in an undergraduate class
um and it is what it is but they're not
big
um on the other hand work on the fermat
problem that's what we like to call it
because
it's not really his theorem because we
don't think he proved it so
i mean work on the vermont problem
developed this like incredible richness
of number theory that we now
live in today like and not by the way
just wiles andrew wiles being
the person who together with richard
taylor finally proved this theorem
but you know how you have this whole
moment that people try to prove this
theorem and they fail
and there's a famous false proof by
lemay from the 19th century
where kumar in understanding what
mistake lemay had made
in this incorrect proof basically
understands something incredible which
is that
you know a thing we know about numbers
is that um
you can factor them and you can factor
them uniquely
there's only one way to break a number
up into primes
like if we think of a number like 12 12
is 2 times 3
times 2. i had to think about it right
or it's 2 times 2 times 3 of course you
can reorder them right
but there's no other way to do it
there's no universe in which 12 is
something times 5
or in which there's like 4 threes in it
nope 12 is like two twos and a three
like that
is what it is and that's such a
fundamental feature
of arithmetic that we almost think of it
like god's law you know what i mean it
has to be that way
so that's a really powerful idea it's
it's so cool
that every number is uniquely made up of
other numbers
and like made up meaning like there's
these like basic atoms
that form molecules that for that
get built on top of each other i love it
i mean when i teach you know
undergraduate number theory it's like
it's the first really deep theorem that
you prove
what's amazing is you know the fact that
you can factor a number into primes
is much easier essentially euclid knew
it although he didn't quite put it in
that
in that way the fact that you can do it
at all what's deep is the fact that
there's only one way to do it that or
however you sort of chop the number up
you end up with the same set of
prime factors and indeed what people
finally understood uh at the end of the
19th century is that
if you work in number systems slightly
more general than the ones we're used to
um which it turns out irrelevant for ma
um all of a sudden this stops being true
things get i mean things get more
complicated and now
because you were praising simplicity
before you were like it's so beautiful
unique factorization
it's so great like so when i tell you
that in more general number
systems there is no unique factorization
maybe you're like that's bad i'm like no
that's good because there's like a whole
new world of phenomena to study that you
just can't see
through the lens of the numbers that
we're used to so i'm
i'm for complication i'm highly in favor
of complication
because every complication is like an
opportunity for new things to study
and is that the big uh kind of uh one of
the big insights for you from uh
andrew wiles is proof is there
interesting insights about
the process they use to prove that sort
of
uh resonates with you as a mathematician
is there an interesting concept that
emerged from it
is there interesting human aspects to
the proof
whether there's interesting human
aspects to the proof itself is an
interesting question
certainly it has a huge amount of
richness sort of at its heart
is an argument of on of what's called
deformation theory
um which was in part
and created by by my phd advisor barry
mazar
can you speak to what deformation theory
is i can speak to what it's like
sure how about that what what does it
rhyme with right
well the reason that barry called it
deformation theory
i think he's the one who gave it the
name um i hope i'm not wrong and saying
this on david in your book you have
calling different things by the same
name as one of the
things in the beautiful map that opens
the book yes and this is a perfect
example so this is another phrase of
poincare this like incredible generator
of slogans and aphorisms he said
mathematics is the art of calling
different things by the same name that
very thing
that very thing we do right when we're
like this triangle and this triangle
come on they're the same triangle
they're just in a different place right
so in the same way um it came to be
understood that
the kinds of objects that you study uh
when you study uh when you study for
maslow's theorem
and let's not even be too careful about
what these objects are i can tell you
there are gal representations in modular
forms but saying those words
is not going to mean so much but
whatever they are they're things that
can be
deformed moved around a little bit
and um i think the insight of what
andrew and
and then andrew and richard were able to
do was to say something like this
deformation means moving something just
a tiny bit like an infinite testable
amount
if you really are good at understanding
which ways a thing can move
in a tiny tiny tiny infinitesimal amount
in certain directions
maybe you can piece that information
together to understand the whole global
space in which it can move
and essentially their argument comes
down to showing that two of those
big global spaces are actually the same
the fabled r
equals t part of uh part of their proof
which is at the heart of it
um and it involves this very
careful uh principle like that but that
being said
what i just said it's probably not what
you're thinking because what you're
thinking
when you think oh i have a point in
space and i move it around like a little
tiny bit
um you're using
um your notion of distance that's you
know from calculus
we know what it means for like two
points on the real line to be
close together so i yet another
thing that comes up in the book a lot is
this fact that
the notion of distance is not given to
us by god
we could mean a lot of different things
by distance and just in the english
language we do that all the time we talk
about somebody being a close relative
it doesn't mean they live next door to
you right it means something else
there's a different notion of distance
we have in mind and there are lots of
notions of distances
that you could use you know in the
natural language processing community
and ai there might be some notion of
semantic distance or lexical distance
between two words how much do they tend
to arise in the same context that's
incredibly important
for um you know doing autocomplete and
like
machine translation and stuff like that
and it doesn't have anything to do with
are they next to each other in the
dictionary right it's a different kind
of distance
okay ready in this kind of number theory
there is a
crazy distance called the periodic
distance i didn't write about this that
much in the book because even though i
love it it's a big part of my research
life it gets a little bit into the weeds
but
your listeners are going to hear about
it now please where
you know what a normal person says when
they say two numbers are close
they say like you know their differences
like a small number like seven and eight
are close because their difference is
one and one's pretty small
um if we were to be what's called a two
attic number theorist
we'd say oh two numbers are close if
their difference
is a multiple of a large power of two
so like so like one and
49 are close because their difference is
48 and 48 is a multiple of 16 which is a
pretty large power of two
whereas whereas one and two are pretty
far away
because the difference between them is
one which is not even a multiple of a
power of two at all it's odd
you wanna know it's really far from one
like
one and 1 64. because their difference
is a negative power of 2
2 to the minus 6. so those points are
quite quite fast
the power of a large n would be too
co if that's the difference between two
numbers and they're close
yeah so two to a large power is this
metal
very small number and two to a negative
power
is a very big number that's two attic
okay uh
i can't even visualize that it takes
practice it takes practice if you've
ever heard of the cantor set it looks
kind of like that
so it is crazy that this is good for
anything right
i mean this just sounds like a
definition that someone would make up to
torment you
but what's amazing is there's a general
theory of distance where you say any
definition you make that satisfy certain
axioms deserves to be called a distance
and this
see i'm starting to interrupt uh my
brain you broke my brain now awesome
uh 10 seconds ago uh because i'm also
starting to map
for the two added case to binary numbers
and sure you know
because because we romanticized those
sources that's exactly the right way to
think of it i was trying to
mess with number and i was starting to
see okay which ones are close
and then i'm starting to visualize
different binary numbers and how they
which ones are close to each other and
uh not sure well i think there's
no it's very similar that's exactly the
way to think of it it's almost like
binary numbers written in reverse
right because in a in a binary expansion
two numbers are close a number that's
small is like point zero zero zero zero
something
something that's the decimal and it
starts with a lot of zeros in the two
attic metric
a binary number is very small if it ends
with a lot of zeros and then the
decimal point got you so it is kind of
like binary numbers written backwards is
actually
i should have that's what i should have
said lex that's a very good metaphor
okay but so why is that why is that
interesting except for the fact that uh
it's it's it's a beautiful kind of uh
framework different kind of framework
for which to think about distances
and you're talking about not just the
two attic but the generalization of that
yeah and so so that and because that's
the kind of deformation that comes up
in wiles is is in wiles's proof that
deformation we're moving something a
little bit
means a little bit in this to addiction
okay no i mean it's such i mean i could
just get excited talking about it and i
just taught this like in the fall
semester that um but it like
reformulating
why is uh
[Music]
so you pick a different uh measure of
distance
over which you can talk about very tiny
changes
and then use that to then prove things
about
the entire thing yes although you know
honestly what i would say
i mean it's true that we use it to prove
things but i would say we use it to
understand things
and then because we understand things
better then we can prove things but you
know the goal is always the
understanding the goal is not to
so much to prove things the goal is not
to know what's true or false i mean this
is something i write about in the book
near the end and it's something that
it's a wonderful wonderful essay by by
bill thurston
kind of one of the great geometers of
our time who unfortunately passed away a
few years ago
um called on proof in progress in
mathematics and he writes very
wonderfully about how
you know we're not it's not a theorem
factory where we have a
production quota i mean the point of
mathematics is to help humans understand
things
and the way we test that is that we're
proving new theorems along the way
that's the benchmark but that's not the
goal yeah but just as a as a kind of
absolutely but as a tool it's kind of
interesting
to approach a problem by saying how can
i change the distance
function like what the the nature of
distance
because that might start to lead to
insights
for deeper understanding like if i were
to try to describe
human society by a distance two people
are close
if they love each other right and then
and then
start to uh and do a full analysis on
the
everybody that lives on earth currently
the seven billion people
you know and from that perspective as
opposed to the geographic perspective
of distance and then maybe there could
be a bunch of insights about the source
of
uh violence the source of uh maybe
entrepreneurial success or invention or
economic success or different systems
communism capitalism start to i mean
that's i guess what
economics tries to do but really saying
okay let's think outside the box about
totally new distance functions that
could unlock something
profound about the space yeah because
think about it okay here's
i mean now we're gonna talk about ai
which you know a lot more about than i
do so
just you know start laughing
uproariously if i say something that's
completely wrong we both know
very little relative to what we will
know
centuries from now that is that is a
really
good humble way to think about it i like
it okay so let's just go for it
um okay so i think you'll agree with
this that
in some sense what's good about ai is
that
we can't test any case in advance the
whole point of ai is to make our one
point of it i guess is to make
good predictions about cases we haven't
yet seen and in some sense that's always
going to involve some notion of distance
because it's always going to involve
somehow taking a case we haven't seen
and saying
what cases that we have seen is it close
to is it like is it somehow an
interpolation
between um now when we do that in order
to talk about things being like other
things
implicitly or explicitly we're invoking
some notion of distance and boy we
better get it right
yeah right if you try to do natural
language processing and your idea about
of distance between words is
how close they are in the dictionary
when you write them in alphabetical
order you are going to get
pretty bad translations right no the
notion of distance has to come from
somewhere else yeah that that's
essentially when neural networks are
doing this what word embeddings are
doing is yes coming up with uh
in the case of word embeddings literally
like literally what they are doing is
learning a distance but those are super
complicated distance functions and
you